use less than greater than or equal to
compare the two fractions 21 28 and 6 9.
now your impulse might just be look at
these numbers and say oh look at these
are larger numbers than those this must
be bigger you cannot do that and we'll
talk about in in future videos on why
that is or i encourage you to think
about why you cannot do that but to do
it properly at least in my mind the best
way is to get these both in simplified
forms and just think about what they
represent and in the future when we
learn to convert them to decimals that's
actually the best way to do it or
actually for me the easiest way but
let's try to do what we can so far so 21
over 28
21 over 28. if we want to put this in in
simplified form 21 is the same thing as
3 times 7
28 is the same thing as 4 times 7.
they're both divisible by 7. now if you
divide the numerator and the denominator
by 7 if you divide both of the 3 times
seven divided by seven is just going to
be three
four times seven divided by seven is
just going to be four so this guy right
here is three fourths is equivalent to
three fourths
now let's think about what 6 9 is
let's think about what 6 9 is
6 over 9. and since these numbers are
smaller this is actually a good chance
to visualize it so let's visualize what
if we have ninths
so we have let me draw the 9 9 first
so if i were to split it into
let's see if i were to split it into
thirds i just want to make it so it's
reasonably no that's not right
maybe there and there
and then divide each of these into
thirds
so just like that now a little bit
more space to that one
and then we have it like that and then
this one into thirds
let me draw it like that
so here we have nine pieces of a candy
bar whatever we want to think about it
or nine ninths six ninths
six ninths literally means one
two three
four
five
six six ninths reference six of the nine
potential pieces or six of these one
ninth of a candy bar pieces however you
want to think about it now six
six is the same thing as
two times three so you could view it as
two groups of three so you could view it
as let me do it this way you could view
it as two groups of three so this is one
group of three
this is one group of three right there
and that is another group of three these
are two groups of three
now what is nine equivalent to
nine is equivalent to
nine is equivalent to three
three times three or three groups of
three so nine is equivalent to that's
one group of three
that is two groups of three
and now this is three groups of three
three groups of three so we could draw
we could redraw this
as so if we just draw just the groups of
three it would look like this
if we just drew the groups of three it
would look like this
it would look like this
and these these six or these two groups
of three that the six represents if we
just draw the groups of three would be
that guy
and that guy
right over there
so how many groups of three do we have
how many how many thirds do we have if
you consider each of those groups of
three is a third well we have two thirds
this is equivalent to two thirds but
doing the process that we're used to
doing
we could imagine
six is two times three nine is three
times three if you divide two times
three by three you get two if you divide
three times three by three
you get three so this six ninths is the
same thing as
two
as two
over
three
two of the of two of the thirds of the
one one-thirds that's what six-ninths is
equivalent to now let's think about
what's larger two-thirds which is the
same thing as six-ninths or
three-fourths i didn't do 21 over 28
because it would have taken forever to
draw so what does three-fourths look
like what is three-fourths so if we were
to take this exact same square so let me
redraw it
so if we take that same exact candy bar
so these should be the same size
instead of cutting up into three pieces
if we were to cut it up into
four pieces what do we get so let's see
that's cutting up into
two pieces and now let me cut it up into
four pieces
so now this one has fourths this one has
thirds three in the denominator here so
let me make it very clear this
represents
two
thirds now this is going to represent
we have four pieces and if we have if
we're coloring in three of them
so if we're talking about three over
four that's one
let me draw it like this actually that
is one
two
let me scroll up a little bit
three this is three of the fourths and
the way i drew it it is not completely
obvious to you actually the way i drew
it because let me draw it a little bit
neater than this
let me draw it a little bit neater and
become a little bit more obvious i
didn't draw the fourths here drawing
neatly actually matters
so let me draw it like that and then
split this group
nope
i want to make it even
so i want to make it like this
okay so those are the fourths if we're
talking about three of the fourths we're
talking about so if we're talking about
three of the fourths we're talking about
one
two
three
fourths and you can see that three
fourths is larger than two-thirds
two-thirds gets us to this far of the
candy bar while three-fourths is a
little bit more of the candy bar
two-thirds is about that far
three-fourths is even more so
three-fourths is larger than two-thirds
and we'll show you in the future how to
do it numerically we can use a
calculator if you like or you can do it
by hand but you can see from this
visually that three-fourths
three-fourths
is greater than two-thirds is greater
than two-thirds now they want us to
compare these two fractions so 21 over
28 is the same thing as three-fourths so
21 over 28 is going to be greater than
two-thirds which is the same thing as
six
over nine
and so we are done